we have
the wizard will clemente joining us uh
will how are you
hey guys i'm good i just got my coffee
in the system so
i got the blockwear uh shirt on here
ready to go
yeah look at that man those are fresh
shirts all right
um all right we got a whole bunch of
stuff we got to get to before we start
though let's start just with like how
are you feeling sentiment wise on
twitter like it seems like people are uh
cautiously optimistic how would you put
it
um
i mean i i think the majority of people
are just
you know cautious to bearish um i think
that it's also kind of like reflected in
derivatives as well
i don't think i mean this kind of sounds
like a cop-out answer but i don't think
anyone is overly
bullish if anything people are kind of
swaying bearish but you know across the
board just seems like everyone's at a
minimum cautious
all right i mean that's not that's not
fun but
that's just where we are right like it
just kind of feels like man there's no
uh there's no catalyst yet to really
ignite all the uh the excitement um yeah
we'll talk about that in a minute
all right uh the first thing i think we
want to talk about is this idea of like
bitcoin and no man's land i think you've
been kind of talking about this for uh
for a little bit um and we've got the
short-term holder cost basis as a
kind of an initial metric to look at but
how do you think about this idea of no
man's land
and how that relates to these short-term
holders
yeah so uh
in the newsletter we've been talking
about this kind of value momentum uh
mental framework for approaching the
market for a while now um to be
transparent this is a mental framework i
stole from my buddy avi feldman who's a
hedge fund manager um but you know i
think in general you have like
momentum-based market participants and
value-based market participants and so
when we're talking about momentum
here at blackberry we kind of see that
as several closes above 47 000
at the current moment and then we see
value as the low 30ks kind of the 30 to
35k area
for the for the value you know
framework that's pretty straightforward
just looking at price structure
for the momentum framework we have two
charts kind of highlighting that in
addition to just the fact that this is a
key area from just like price
interaction um as well as it's right
around the yearly open the first chart
though we have up is the short term
holder cost basis so we've talked about
this i feel like a million times here in
the show
essentially this is just the aggregated
cost basis of all the entities that have
been in the market for less than 155
days or less than three months
and so this is telling you
you know where that that average cost
basis is for those market participants
and that has a lot of kind of behavioral
effects when price approaches that area
so in bull markets whenever we retest
that those new market participants don't
want to sell at a loss when bitcoin is
in a several month aggressive uptrend
when we head into the bear though um
every time we get an underside re-test
of that cost basis people look to exit
and break even
and so as you can see recently that push
up to 47k we couldn't hold that on
several consecutive closes
and so that does appear like it was a
failed underside retest
and you see confluence in the second
chart
which is the exponential whole moving
average
for this i'm looking at the 180 period
weekly version of this
essentially this is like a moving
average that has a bit more weight like
weighing to recent price action so kind
of like a smoothing factor
the reg is just telling you that the
moving average is declining
so this is actually a good kind of like
high time frame uh indicator to look at
as you can see in 2018 this turned red
you know several weeks before that final
capitulation
um again you know this this does look
like we just experienced this failed
kind of underside uh retest similar to
kind of like mid 2018 um but again i i
think you know there's there's
confluence across several things that
closing above that 47k area we can start
talking about momentum coming back into
the market um but as long as we're below
i don't think it's you know
it's wise from like a high time frame
perspective to step in as like a
value-based market participant so above
47k for that momentum threshold low 30s
for that value threshold and that's
where kind of the me saying where no
man's land came from because we're kind
of in between those two makes uh makes
complete sense and then if we look at
this one day correlation between bitcoin
to the nasdaq uh i haven't seen very
many people looking at the one day
correlations uh what's going on here
this looks pretty crazy
yeah it's really unprecedented so this
is just looking at the as you said one
day correlation of bitcoin to the nasdaq
as you can see we're in you know
really
extremely high territory of correlation
um we had set like a new record at the
beginning of 2022 for the highest
correlation ever or kind of kind of
highest block of sustained correlation
ever we broke that over the last week or
two so as you can see in the on the
bottom right hand of the right right
hand side of the chart this big block of
blue essentially that's just telling you
that the correlation is high uh and so
you can see that kind of orange line i
drew that was the prior all-time high uh
we pushed above that over the last week
it's currently sitting at 0.98
which is very high i mean bitcoin is
essentially just kind of trading tick
for tick with the nasdaq
um and so you know i think
uh we'll talk about this in a second
this has kind of been one of the driving
forces obviously around bitcoin price
action um and so you've seen that kind
of rebound in tech you know towards the
you know end of last month and you kind
of seen that roll over this month over
the last few weeks
and that's obviously translated into btc
as well and you know whether bitcoiners
view bitcoin this way or not and we'll
talk about in a second some of the
metrics that are illustrating that
bitcoiners beneath the surface are
stacking btc and
kind of convicted as ever
you know kind of the marginal
you know
buyer or seller
is viewing btc as kind of this high beta
asset basketing it in with tech
got it and so when you think about this
correlation um talk to me a little bit
about the
there's decoupling right so like the
correlation goes down uh there's also
this idea that like tech socks could
just explode people go kind of risk on
again uh it sounds like you think the
decoupling is more likely to be uh what
happens than like there's a recovery in
risk assets is that fair
yeah um so i think you know for btc to
to move up you know just from first
principles
you need either one of two things and it
boils down to either a you need tech
stocks to rebound and that would drag
btc up if we have the sustained period
of high correlation
the other way btc could move up would be
if that correlation broke down
um and so
with that in mind i think for the for
the latter i mean for the former talking
about tech stocks rebounding i think
darius actually did a really good job
and i'm not going to get into that
because
i think he was he really nailed it on
head he's more the expert in that realm
let's talk about like what it would take
for tech stocks to rebound um one of the
biggest things obviously just being like
the fed being extremely hawkish
but for the decoupling piece i think
that's where i could maybe provide
listeners a bit more value with some
kind of bitcoin-centric data points um
and so like for this decoupling to
theoretically
occur
you know i think first first just
highlighting the fact that markets move
in kind of these pendulum swings
what i mean by that is like they go from
extreme to extreme and this happens not
only with price action but also like
narratives and trends in the market and
the trend obviously we're talking about
here is is the correlation to the nasdaq
so i mean when you go back and look at
the chart whenever the correlation gets
extremely high uh you could even see
this at the beginning of this year it
went from getting to an all-time high
and then came all the way back down to
negatives and so you get this kind of
pendulum swing that goes back and forth
and when everyone when everyone on
twitter is talking about you know this
correlation and it becomes consensus
that tends to be when that that pendulum
is beginning to start to swing the other
direction so i think that's one thing
just to keep like preset in your mind
the fact that we've had this prolonged
sustain of regime of strong correlation
to nasdaq um so but for that for that
decoupling to occur you need either like
two things either in the short term some
type of idiosyncratic flow meaning you
know some like large buyers stepping in
uh the luna foundation guard and dokon
stepping in and buying this you know
several billion dollars in btc has been
one example of that um you know sailor
was another example um so i think you
know if you had some large entity that
stepped in um that could drive
idiosyncratic flow in the short term and
cause btc to to decouple in the short
term i think from the from a broader
sense and and
um
this i have a bit more high conviction
on because you know it's hard to say is
large buyer gonna step in or not
in a broader sense i think what the data
is showing you is that
beneath the surface you have a lot of
these um crypto native high net worth
individual kind of forward-looking
institutions that are viewing btc as a
store of value and you know despite all
of the uncertainty we've got
geopolitically and just mark in markets
in general um you're seeing several
metrics which we'll look at the charts
in a moment um illustrating the fact
that these holders are just holding
right and so you kind of have this
dichotomy of
a lot of these traditional finance
entities that are viewing btc as you
know a high data tech asset uh and then
these convicted crypto natives um or
just people that understand the value
proposition of bitcoin and they're
holding you know during this time of
uncertainty this is the time that you
know bitcoin was built for right we have
inflation extremely high geopolitical
uncertainty um and so i think what's
kind of going on beneath the surface is
uh my buddy suzu eloquently kind of
phrased this to me as like a supply
gentrification and i think you kind of
have this um transfer of supply from
that one basket of entities i talked
about to the other
and so i think kind of this sideways
range that we've been in is an
illustration of equilibrium between the
transfer of the two of those entities
and so i guess with that we could dive
into a few of the charts that i have to
kind of back up that thesis so let's do
this idea of how much supply hasn't
moved in the last 12 months um and
you're comparing the seven-day moving
average uh off of the nasdaq high we
were just talking about a bunch of
stocks just
getting actually decimated uh in the
stock market so what's this showing us
yep so in green you're looking at the
seven day moving average of the nasdaq
uh the percentage of the nasdaq off its
highest
and so
you can see right now we're about 18
roughly or today it might be closer to
20
um i haven't looked at what the nasdaq's
doing in the last like 45 minutes
because i've been writing the newsletter
um
but i know i know it's down today so it
might be down closer to 20
uh point is though nasdaq down fairly
substantially at the same time you have
an all-time high in the amount of supply
that hasn't moved in at least a year and
that's that orange line
or i should say orange kind of area or
shaded area
and so this is honestly pretty
remarkable when you think about it right
you have an all-time high amount of
supply that hasn't moved in at least a
year meaning people are sitting on their
btc convicted as ever
despite all the uncertainty we have that
we just kind of described darius did a
great job describing earlier today um
and so
to me what this is showing is that
there's this toddler base right this
convicted toddler base that they're just
they view btc as their store value i
think you know a lot of kind of um
there's there's been several
catalysts even just this year
um
you know for example russia getting
their fx reserve frozen maybe it's just
inflation running high or just over the
last year as bitcoin ran up people
taking interest in understanding the
value prop of bitcoin um the fact that
you've got this growing toddler base uh
and i i think this is honestly pretty
remarkable the fact that you have people
holding with conviction to this extent
uh despite all the uncertainty and and
this is exactly what you know bitcoin
was built for
so when you see this it seems like uh
there's very much a battle right you
talked about this a little bit earlier
between uh the bitcoin holders who treat
this as the reserve asset won't sell it
and then that whole idea of like the
traders the people who are worried about
macro look at this as a risk asset etc
is that really the uh supply
gentrification that you're talking about
and that is what leads to that
decoupling and so it's like we
understand that the bases are different
today but we've got to get concentration
into the holders and as that occurs
which is already underway but as that
continues that's really what'll uh
provide the foundation for uh for kind
of explosive moves in the future
yeah i think so that's kind of my thesis
is that in the next 12 months
conservatively we'll kind of see that
transfer complete i think once that
completes then you'll start to see that
that decoration once that supply
transfer has
uh completed and so yeah i think you
summed it up well there um
we can look at two other charts like
briefly just to like uh nail that point
home the second one is just looking at
the exchange net position change
so this is the 30-day change in exchange
balances
uh this has started to roll back over
over the last week or two back into this
like little blue grade i don't even know
what color that is
zone that i highlighted there
um that's showing you the um
the rate of outflows is the fourth low
of the fourth you know highest that it's
ever been so you're seeing a strong
amount of outflows uh from exchanges
coins coming out of exchanges so that's
another accumulation metric and then the
last one is looking at whale balances i
think this is uh
the most interesting one aside from the
supply last
moved in over a year this is looking at
all the entities with over a thousand
btc and then we're filtering out all the
known entities that um glassnode has
identified on chains so otc desks
exchanges obviously is a huge one for
for obvious reasons um grayscale qbtc
the purpose etf and so what you get is
essentially this kind of filtered whale
balances metric and that's that green
line
on top of that i've overlaid these kind
of color changes and so that's just
showing you when their balances are
increasing starting to make
you know higher lows versus decreasing
uh and so what you can see is that
the their holdings have been increasing
over the last month and also when this
little box i drew is just essentially
highlighting this downtrend that their
holdings have been in since september
and i think we're starting to see the
early days of perhaps a break out of
that downturn i think it might be a
little too early to like solid solidly
call that a break out of the downtrend
until at least we push above those those
uh the highs in their holdings from
september at the end of last year but
nonetheless we have seen accumulation
over the last
month or so from from wales which is
interesting in confluence with some of
those other things that we just
mentioned and
so i think you know
that's kind of like building the case i
mean there's a few other metrics but i
tried to keep it like relatively short
just for the the sake of the newsletter
um but you know i think we're kind of
building this case for this supply
transfer over the next year or so um you
know i've talked to a few people that
think that perhaps happens closer to
like the end of
q2 and q3 uh i think conservatively in
the next uh 12 months
so when you see this all going on right
now uh i see luna foundation obviously
buying a bunch of bitcoin hundred plus
million dollars a day uh there's rumors
slash maybe it's been confirmed at this
point that justin son is going to go and
he's going to replicate the same thing
like is that something from a catalyst
standpoint that could just be a bunch of
these stable coins all start backing
their stable coins with bitcoin and
there's enough buy pressure to really
kind of uh change the dynamic in the
market the price has to go up to
accommodate everyone
yeah i mean i think if um you know if
tron started to back their you know
reserve like reserves of bitcoin that
would be
more in the camp of talking about like
those short-term idiosyncratic flows but
then as well it somewhat ties also into
the basket and so does everything that
dokkan's been doing of that supply
transfer to crypto natives um
and you know by the way i think like
whenever this
whenever this transfer finally completes
um and if if a decoupling theoretically
did occur
i think it would have um
i think first of all would be quite
powerful right and the second thing is i
think would have a lot of reflexivity
meaning you know as you start to see
that decoupling
people are looking at this and saying
wow
you know crypto and bitcoin more
specifically is is moving independently
um you know i need to take note of this
and
almost that they're kind of fomo of
missing out on that um that that change
in in trend of correlation kicks in and
that drives the correlation even further
um so george soros talks about this idea
of reflexivity i think that's extremely
present in in the bitcoin market um but
i think it applies to narratives as well
and i think you know a decoupling which
is something that hasn't really occurred
for the last two or three years since
large institutional players really
started getting involved in bitcoin i
think that would have a high aspect of
reflexivity to it
yeah it um it definitely feels like uh
when you and i started doing these uh
conversations in the summer of 2021 that
was uh very obvious that we were kind of
going through this consolidation uh and
at some point people got kind of tired
with the message right or bored of the
message of like oh it's building it's
building it's building it's like yeah
like a big portion of it is just being
patient and then when it happens
it explodes right and when it explodes
everyone's kind of in hysteria and like
how did that happen but these are the
moments where you almost lay the
groundwork for those explosive moves and
nobody knows is it a week away is it a
year away right it's really really hard
to kind of understand that uh but
definitely a lot of these metrics i
think are telling a story that is pretty
compelling
yeah and i mean i think
it would be difficult to get some
massive capitulation like you know a lot
of people are talking about well we
didn't have you know we haven't had like
a bear market capitulation um i think a
couple things about that so first of all
like we didn't have a capitulation in my
mind to the upside during this
quote-unquote cycle or whatever you want
to call it over the last two years um
the second thing is all these metrics
that we've just described you know we're
seeing heavy accumulation i think that's
almost acting as a force pushing up
against uh the cell side pressure right
and the third thing is like the
positioning in the derivatives market
so we've talked on previous shows about
the percentage of the futures contracts
collateralized bitcoin versus stable
coins has come down about 50
and so the convexity of those of those
contracts the setup of the the current
uh futures market right now has a lot
less potential convexity if if we did
get some type of capitulatory spiral
then it was set up uh in march 2020 i
mean the other thing too is people were
jacked up heading into the having at
that time the futures market now is
relatively defensive in positioning uh
and then the other argument i would make
to that is like the liquidation engines
of the current exchanges that are
dominating uh volume especially like ftx
is a lot less aggressive than bit neck
so
uh unless we had
some you know massive capitulation in
macro in traditional markets which i
think would
you know just cause margin calls in in
btc as well because in that case people
have to sell what they have to what they
can sell not what they want to sell um
but aside from that i think it's it
would be difficult to see some huge
capitulation that a lot of people are
kind of um theorizing
what is uh what are you looking forward
to most over the next like month 30 days
in terms of markets or just like in life
in general you mean no markets oh
um
i think i think it'll be interesting to
see
do we see follow-through for the fed
like from the fed first of all um and
the second thing is inflation obviously
like do we start to see at least like
the month over month uh numbers start to
peak i think that could drive
although i think we both understand
there's kind of this like relativity
bias to that right but um i think that
could drive this like at least
short-term narrative of oh inflation is
peaked um and you know i think a lot of
politicians would kind of like try to
like hammer that drum especially as we
uh you know
the democrats are where they're you know
not i don't like to get political but
you know the fact is the democrats are
you know facing a lot of uh you know
political headwinds right now from
inflation so i think if that started to
occur i think that would be a narrative
that would start to really kind of like
get driven by by those entities
completely agree all right we gotta go
but can we get a uh a quick plug where
can uh people follow you on the internet
sure w clementi iii on twitter uh you
can check out our newsletter at
blackwaterintelligence.com but thanks
for having me on pump really appreciate
it and uh i'll see you next week you're
doing a fantastic job my friend i
appreciate it very much and uh next
friday you'll be back
absolutely all right later you guys
enjoy that miami weather i'm i'm missing
it man
you come you're moving here eventually
bye yeah eventually bye
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time